it takes years to build an empire
they're founded on painstaking
sacrifices
crushing defeats and glorious victories
god help me and i want measure
they're forged by unforgettable moments
and acts that transcend
into legend stewie's on his phone but
look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie
but empires are far from perfect do you
still like playing counter-strike
no after that game
this game i hate this game god gaben
you suck so much to make it video games
it [ __ ] hurts me bro as
unrest spreads among its people so do
rumors
of revolution and from these whispers
has emerged a usurper to the throne you
really think valerian is really good
it's incredible it's one of the greatest
games i've played in a very very
very long time a true contender
backed by its own history of conquest
offering the promise
of change just on the other side he's
able to get one
looking for the second and he's gonna
have to back up gets challenged
as well and he gets the reset it's over
there
oh my gosh but this challenger's not
interested in borrowing the crowd
they're playing
for keeps
[Music]
yeah that's all donna
before we talk about the future we have
to talk about the past
because for nearly as long as there have
been esports
one tactical shooter has dominated
counter-strike
for many fans and future professionals
playing in crowded
internet cafes and in hotel ballrooms
the game was a love affair from which
they never really recovered as esports
grew
counter-strike followed global offensive
became the premier first-person shooter
in esports one of the biggest things
about counter-strike just how it's
always been evolving but yet the
fundamentals of it haven't really
changed at all
and it's community involvement that i
think has been so big to the growth of
it over time
but games and players expectations
were changing do you still like playing
counter-strike no
dead game i just like don't believe that
they're not
updating counter-strike go it needs
change changes
cs is undeniably dying
and yet players are still getting paid
like 40 grand a month
it's [ __ ] crazy if you were a player
who wanted the same
slow tactical feel of counter-strike
but with more content and a more
communicative developer
there was nothing really out there and
if you were a new player looking at
playing your first tactical shooter
starting counter-strike with no prior
experience
was an intimidating prospect i got
underneath yukon
door
ah calling right there oh my god dude
but in 2020 riot games finally gave
both of these groups an option
[Applause]
project a is our character-based
tactical shooter
it's competitive it has precise gun play
it's set on a beautiful near future
earth
and it has a lethal cast of characters
each with their own unique abilities
this is our take on a competitive
shooter the road to get there
had been long valorent was according to
game director joe ziegler
over six years in the making but even as
the first glimpses of gameplay saw the
light of day
the questions emerged
so it's like it looks like csgo with
overwatch ultimates right think guys
guys guys
the gameplay gives me a feel between cs
and overwatch
and the environment gives me a feel a
realm royale for some reason
so like a lot of people are commenting
on the style of
art anyone else kind of get a t i
honestly reminds me of team fortress
at first it was unclear exactly what the
game was
it had abilities
[Music]
it had different agents so the thing
about the molotovs in this game
is if you're playing phoenix your
molotovs hurt your teammates they hurt
your enemies
but they heal you one behind one behind
the leash
imagine me having to wait to tell you
guys
that we don't have to worry about the
molotov from ourselves
you know what i mean it had a res
let's watch this i like this
[Music]
revive me dead
dead you right now yes you're all dead
please revive me was this cs
or was it overwatch as the discussion
raged
there was nothing to do but wait until
players and streamers could get the game
in their own hands but as riot revealed
more
it was clear that the game formerly
known as project a
got its genes from counter-strike they
had brought volcano
a legend of cs map design on board to
help
i'm sal garozzo and i'm a game designer
working primarily on maps
we're definitely going with a slower
more methodical approach with a lot of
the movement in the game but we also
want those outplay moments where
somebody does something incredible and
they could win a 1v4
if they're aiming well enough and we
think that those two things going hand
in hand you know where positioning
ability usage
and individual mechanical skill combined
to create something special
the agent's abilities sometimes replace
traditional utility
like smoke grenades or molotovs
purchased in cs
in other cases they added completely new
functionality
like vision that cs just never had
there were other similarities too like a
bolt action sniper rifle
conspicuously called the op
for the first time in decades
counter-strike had a global competitor
that was trying to do what it did but in
a more modern package
one two three hallelujah
hallelujah
headshot no match
dude to the pro players and streamers
who played valorent before it went
public
the game was already in a great spot
it's just a bunch of government
[Music]
buddy hopping and everyone's walking
that's what it is it's a snooze fest but
i'm addicted and
it sucks you really think valerian is
really good it's
incredible like i can't say i can't say
anything in detail but i can tell you it
was
it's one of the greatest games i've
played in a very very very
long time in week one of the public
closed beta
the game's popularity skyrocketed on
twitch
with 1.7 million concurrent viewers
a record only surpassed by the league of
legends world's 2019 viewership
but even as hype around the game
exploded
valve took notice and took action
it seemed like valve was clearly aware
of valoran's rising popularity
but some players were a little skeptical
so here's a question how long how long
has the sig been
okay and you're telling me three days
after valrant comes out
we're [ __ ] hauling ass now all of a
sudden huh we're just
we're just kicking into high gear and
fixing something we hated forever okay
all right yeah i see you no one's
falling for it right now brother okay
you better hope valor fails valorent's
official release was set for june
2nd 2020 and while offering keys to the
beta as twitch drops
surely helped there was also a feeling
that the game's popularity
meant it could be more than just a
colorful second fiddle to cs
it could be a true competitor
potentially going to spot him give him
away dicey in the smoke
just on the other side he's able to get
one looking for the second and he's
gonna have to back up gets challenged
get through
one as well he gets the reset
dicey does it oh my gosh that feeling
led many in the cs competitive scene to
consider where their careers were headed
and to pick valorant as their next step
big names like
heco scream and nitro eventually took
the opportunity to start fresh
in a new game that shared plenty of
similarities with the old one
so my expectations from valor is going
to be really high of course
since i'm leaving cs and i've been
playing cs my whole life and cs has
given me a lot
so i expect valerian to to to give me
something as well
it's really interesting for for cs
players like us because
we've been playing cs for like 15 years
and everything is always the same
and it has been the same for all the
time so having a new
like a new fresh game is really good for
for me at least
it really gives me motivation and and i
love playing that game and it's really
addicting
other names like wardell made their way
to the game and
found that they could shine brighter
here than they ever could in cs
especially in north america where the
region's best talent
had been mostly gobbled up by its tier
one organizations
so like i knew like playing this game in
beta and then getting really good at
before anybody else before this game
blows up would have been the best
opportunity for me then just rather stay
in cs and just like
wait for something magical to happen if
ballarat didn't go well then i could
always go back to cs right
so then that's what i did and for some
like brax it was a fresh start a chance
to create the career
that is banned from official valve cs go
events had eliminated
as valerian gained a foothold worldwide
it was clear that riot's approach to
making changes and adding content
was very very different from valve but
even at this early stage
valorent was not without its own
controversies
dude the game's anti-cheat system was
one of the first
counter strike had witnessed several of
its own cheating scandals over the years
and they had damaged esports orgs and
even hurt entire regions
when we went and and and scouted in
india
for and obviously it turned out a [ __ ]
show because of that [ __ ] cheater
forsaken loser
put to put on that brand and to [ __ ]
do that like he is lucky
like that i wasn't in there riot's
solution for valorant
was vanguard the system's kernel level
driver upset some players
particularly as early versions of the
anti-cheat interfered with programs that
controlled
cooling and fan speeds for those that
don't know riot's anti-cheat
has kernel access to your computer for
those who don't know that's bad
without getting into the specifics
that's very bad i get why they wanted to
make this incredible anti-cheat because
games like counter-strike did a whole
lot of hacks around them and they wanted
to be as competitive and tight and as
honorable and honest as possible without
people cheating their way to the top
but i think they went way too hard here
i mean this anti-cheat has access to all
your [ __ ]
but even after those issues were
addressed even after
several years of work and the driver
level access
some people were still able to cheat
piece by piece they'll work this
rare taking out good seat we spoke about
good steve's performance and okay traded
back in kind for raya as well
with agent abilities taking the place of
utility
balance has also been a challenge it's
not enough to just nerf guns and utility
riot have to balance the entire agent
abilities and all
that line
dude holy
[Applause]
and while some agents have become the de
facto pick
others are still struggling to find a
niche even after buffs
there have been other stumbling blocks
with valorent's slightly slower movement
the op has become far more oppressive
than its green predecessor
a thing that the balance team is already
trying to address
the game needs to have more ways to
counter offers because right now
ops are way too powerful on defense side
and like i'm telling like i'm saying
teams are double sometimes even triple
hopping because it's literally
impossible to push off all the angles
there's not enough flashes there's not
smokes there's not enough utility
personally i think ops should be like
kind of a risk versus reward kind of
thing
so if you make it like five maybe like
five and a half
then it might be more of like uh oh [ __ ]
do i buy it off because if we lose this
round
i might not be able to buy next round
and then we'll really be [ __ ] while
valerian got off to a hot start on
twitch
counter has retained its spot among the
rankings
at least so far it's still early days
for valor and esports but the
tournaments hosted so far
like the riot-backed ignition series and
now the first strike qualifiers
have provided exactly what viewers want
an opportunity to see how their
favorites stack up
in the still new competitive landscape
and to see the game's meta evolve
that means a new stage for big
eco names for double and now it's all
down to him this is gonna have to be a
quad kill for him to pull things through
and keep him alive he's able to get the
triple
and he doesn't know where the last
player is alexander he's creeping
these guys break around the rosies and
he's creeping out he curry doesn't know
he's got no intel at all oh and he's
using the huntress fury and that's a
good way to beat the time and he makes
no way
a second chance for cs players fighting
to prove themselves
we'll try to back away here not before
taking down shanks and maybe now he
likes his chances after that one
two players left dropping into the side
oh no
oh no oh my god has he done that plenty
of times for the defuse it is pedestrian
here for wardell and a first opportunity
for a bright
new generation of stars this is going to
be a mess
the operator misses the drone is trying
to get some damage in luckily
cutler's there to sort of build him up
but it's completely missed he gets
free he just buys this could be a crazy
ace what the hell is bjorn doing
sensing an opportunity some of the
biggest organizations in esports
have already stepped in to support those
players
without concrete long-term plans for
valorance esports future
it's still difficult to say exactly what
the future holds
but there's optimism from some of the
game's
biggest fans valor is just going to hit
and it's going to hit
hard yeah once land starts jumping out
dude it's going to grow like an
explosion right
it has the perfect recipe right now if
valorent nails the timing
of coming to land and like tournaments
are
popping off it's gonna blow up even more
than it already has
and what we know for sure is that for
once
there's a new competitor in tactical
shooters and whether you buy a vandal
or an ak-47 it's making both games
better oh my god the 13 oh wait no i got
this they're coming short that's me
this is me this is wardell
i don't lose these open up the [ __ ]
gates
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages